hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about how to do a flip jealous pain so
flagella are these extremely thin tail
like appendages that have this like whip
like motion or rotating motion that are
used for motility ice on the cells so
some bacteria some archaea and
eukaryotic cells can have these flagella
now they are difficult to see
pretty much impossible to see under
light microscope unless you use a
special stain and this is because of
this one characteristic because they are
so extremely then they need a special
stain in order to be viewed and so let's
talk about the procedure of that stain
first they're treated with some kind of
mordant which is something to help the
stain stick that is usually in this
stain tannic acid it is really important
in this particular stain because it gets
added to the flagella and it coats the
flagella and thickens the flagella and
really makes it big enough to be
viewable under a light microscope so
after the mordant is put on the next
thing that is applied is the stain and
there's a couple of different stains
that are traditionally used one is para
rose outline the other is basic fuchs in
whichever one of those you use it's
going to give sort of a magenta or a
fuchsia like color and that allows you
to visualize the flagella to determine a
if the cell has flagella B how many it
has and see what arrangement that might
be on is it on both of the poles is it
on just one of the poles is that all
around the cell that kind of thing now
there are some really special
considerations when using this stain one
is that you need to leave the specimen
on the slide and the water drop
disturbed for about 20 minutes after
transferring into the slide this is
because the flagella need that time to
sort of regenerate and extend so that
they can be stained and made visible
also no blotting or heat fixing why and
that's because flagella are just so
fragile so after transfer they need
about 20 minutes undisturbed on the
slide to regenerate and and to extend
and they can be viewable blotting or
heat fixing will actually break off the
flagella until you won't be able to see
them and so that's why you have to take
these considerations into account when
doing this thing if you're interested in
learning about some other microbiology
stands at the Gram stain yeah acid
fasting the endospore stain the capsules
stain I have videos on all of those so
take a look at those and I hope you have
learned a lot thanks for watching
biology professor